[Music]
get down
our parents are all animators
we're we're famous oh
yes baby
what if they're all like we don't need
your help get out of here you apostate
shunned we'd rather die than get your
help
oh wow but thanks though seriously what
a way to open yeah I kicks up the water
yes baby
Gorge then they're all like
see what I
he said the grow good wait hold up oh
that is a Pergo Tommy Tommy that's
Action Baby Ezra Bridger It's gotta be
thrawn thrawn well we know thrawn is out
there but just seeing the Pergo means
that uh uh where the Pergo go we're
gonna see where Ezra Bridger wins he is
gonna show up what an episode oh I love
the way this season is beginning they're
giving us everything we could ever dream
you know sleeping through the whole
thing
Goku will never tell him yeah never
needs to tell him no keep it a secret
it's just our little secret broken
welcome back to new rock stars the
Mandalorian season three premiere is
here burgles have been spotted
hyperspace bocaton is working on ass
Groove into the stone Throne on her home
planet we should say kalavala I saw Ash
Grove at Warped to her they were amazing
you're incredible oh okay good I well I
hope you got the shirt I did yeah they
they were great they were great uh also
our baby grogu yeah it's spinning in
chairs I'm about to spin right out of
this oh wait that's enough
that's enough wow full rotation 360
Degrees
dank ferret it's good to be back we are
here in the new rockstars break group
set this is new rock stars the break
room presents lucky links a Mandalorian
after show it's been so long Tommy Eric
I have been holding my breath the entire
time waiting waiting for us to come back
and talk about Mandalorian you know
we've had some bumps we've had some
bruises but I think we've come out of
hyperspace a little bit wiser I like to
think so too you know we were doing
Wikileaks during and or not a ton of
people were watching and or so we took a
little break from Wikileaks but you know
what we're back we cannot say no that's
right to do to doing these after shows
for the Mandalorian season three I'm
Eric boss I'm here with Tommy back told
great to be here all my Wookie freaks
out there Daddy's home and the other
Daddy's home and we've brought some
friends we came back with those
cigarettes from the corner store they
said we're getting we follow through on
our promises now as always my Easter egg
breakdown of this episode of the
Mandalorian is coming out tomorrow on
the new rockstars Channel and if you're
interested you can watch my raw rambling
ridiculous live stream that I did on the
Deep dive channel uh as I was in the
process of writing my breakdown so if
it's a little unrefined that will be why
but right now right here Tommy and I are
going to discuss this season three
premiere of the Mandalorian we're going
to answer the big questions coming on
this episode and there were quite a few
times absolutely but before we can get
into it we got to talk about these sweet
sweet shirts we're wearing this is all
part of the nerd Riot dot shop the way
collection the way Eric is wearing the
Bounty Hunter I am wearing the foundling
when you go to nerd right at that shop
and buy one of these you have the option
to purchase a custom shout out that will
be playing along the bottom of our
Wikileaks episodes and maybe said aloud
by Eric or myself and like I said these
ain't just shout out to my nephew shout
out to my brother shout out to my sister
you want to file for divorce via one of
those shout outs we'll do it we don't
care we have no moral qualms if you want
to uh shout out your three possible dads
and try to invite all three of them to
your wedding that's right figure out
which one is the real dad you can do
that via shout out if you like we would
love to do that I mean it might get a
little costly but honestly can you put a
price on family I know I can that's why
I moved away let's recap the episode
yeah okay so the episode begins with
this like armorer monster yeah we get we
get we get we get the the sounds of the
hard-working through the the iconic
faces of Star Wars opening that usually
is the like
I love that by the way instead of the
blue and red lights like to me that is
better than the Marvel Studios time
record I have to say I know that's
sacrilege to the Disney heads out there
I just think it's cooler I think it
looks cooler a mark out for yeah so we
see the armorer
making a bike helmet for a kid
um this a kid who's going through this
baptism yes I love some good culty Game
of Thrones [__] yeah that's how we start
we this show is getting back to its
roots as the Mandalorian and like yes it
is about grogu and Mando but at its
heart it is a show about a cult who do
not realize that they are part of a cult
that's absolutely right I love a
Beachside ceremony I'm a sucker for it
but most of my Beachside ceremonies end
in disaster and this one was no
different that's right yeah we were
trying to figure out what exactly this
big beast is uh it uh it may actually be
a Star Wars thing it's just slipping our
minds right now but it looks like a
giant crocodile yeah I think it kind of
looks like an alligator snapping turtle
which is a real creature that haunts my
nightmares Google alligator snapping
turtle imagine another set of legs on it
tell me that's not what that thing looks
like yeah so they're about to die some
people are getting eaten some people are
getting swatted around kids are still in
the mix that's right and then who swoops
in Mando Baby
by the way I wanna first of all a little
credit to the to the other mandalorians
some pretty ingenious ways of taking
that thing down they put the little uh
the little Detonator
detonators on there but uh they try to
try the spirit but in the end only a
Naboo star Cruiser could take it down
now do you think do you think so the kid
the kid is Wesley Kimmel yes it was
Jimmy Kimmel's nephew yes uh and a son
of Jonathan Kimmel who works on the
Jimmy Kimmel show as well right and uh
and if that kid looks familiar he's the
kid from the West View commercials in
one Division I believe it's episode five
it's the one wherever there's the Lagos
paper towels that's that's Wesley Kimmel
as well
um so uh but yeah so this kid do you
think he's positive son oh that's pretty
cool was like real proud he was a real
proud Holy Communion Papa and he also
immediately was like oh the kids get out
of here yeah he like pushed some kids
out of the way now maybe he didn't want
those kids to claim the glory yeah so
um Mando saves them no one thanks him no
uh but then he goes and he chats with
the armor yeah he's like hey we good and
she's like absolutely nothing I've had
this conversation what did I say yeah
you need to go to The Living Water the
Marriott Residence Inn on Mandalore and
go sit in the hot tub for a little bit
and they're like well we all are pretty
sure that there's the fusion crystals
are all over it right yeah and those are
Living Waters there's a lot of living
things in those Waters a lot of bacteria
and things that we don't want to speak
of yeah but it was interesting he uh
presented this thing the scrap of like
green it looks like glass that was uh
irradiated by lightning or whatever
these Fusion bombs that were dropped
over sundari but preserved was some
mandoa text and to him he's like if they
were able to recover it it can't be that
radioactive yeah somebody they said what
like a scavenger was able to survive
right if they can survive it can't be
that bad
um so they use that as evidence of okay
maybe maybe it's worth going back to it
grogu is fascinating to watch in the
scene he looks up at that Mythos are uh
head on the wall
um just it's fun to watch this episode
Through The Eyes of Mando or Through The
Eyes of grogu specifically the next
scene yeah going through hyperspace
Mando passed out yeah grogu looking out
and it's like I was like what is he
gonna call out to I was like is he going
to like call out to to like some some
Force sensitive being turns out he
called out to something pretty freaking
incredible yes yes the Virgo hyperspace
whales now do you think he called out I
don't know if he called out to him but
he didn't see him okay we're going to
talk more about the pearls in a second
they're very very very important
obviously um okay so they go to Navarro
and Navarro looks what a glow up it's
like Detroit in 2015 if you've been to
Detroit anytime prior to
there's brand new bars and restaurants
open some of the bars have even become
schools now if you could combine the two
I'm in business and I'm moving there
also grief cargo is now what the grand
magistrate he's got two little droids
who just carry his cake that was I mean
just what I think I'm out of ways for
Star Wars to make Droids that are
hilarious you know they have the garbage
can droids which I love they make now
they have cloak carrying drugs which you
assume are functional for weddings right
yeah but griefcrog is like no I got two
of those the kawakian monkey lizards are
now in a tree they're repopulating they
used to be on The Spits we've got a
we've got a multi-spece or a multi-uh
race band with some Twilight oh we saw
mon calamari
calamari yeah very exciting
um and then yeah so grief cargo Grand
magistrate now offers Mando some uh some
parcels he's like you want to be part of
the landed gentry I mean he can't stop
offering him jobs yeah he's like would
you like to be a landowner I can give
you a nice spot over by the hot springs
yeah come on those Living Waters huh you
got some babes and throws hot springing
and then Mando's like no I can't he's
like settle down with you I love he's
just like take your son and settle down
not like hey go out find a life partner
he's like just take your kid and train
and we get this great moment Carl
Weathers like you and your little one
he's like grogu he's like what did you
just say to me is that something's name
he's like yes his name is and he's like
if you say so yeah like just like most
of the viewing audience we will not call
him grogu we will call him grogu Heroes
but most of you out there I still I
still whisper baby Yoda every time I'm
like grogu baby
but also we got a great scene where
grogu is whipping himself around using
the force and then he pulls a little
candy out of the dish using the force
using the force the way a normal person
would exactly enough of this Mark Hamill
Luke Skywalker goody goody [__] you
know what I'm saying I would stop at one
piece of candy just grab the whole
freaking bone you know what I would do
if I had the force I'd be laying on the
couch and I always lose the remote I
would just be sticking my hand out
summoning a remote from somewhere in the
room and my life would be so much easier
uh yeah it truly would well uh oh
Pirates uh we see some Pirates led by
vayne uh this guy who wants a drink at
the school I believe that is the same
Navarro school where grogu stole some
cookies right yeah led by that uh
protocol Droid I think that's the same
school same classroom or maybe just some
other school used to be a bar grogu's
still using it as a bar if he's eating
cookies that's right uh but anyway they
get into this awesome Gunslinger
shootout yes with the Pirates and they
get we go back to the Great Western
Stingers they have
uh we see ig-11 has been immortalized in
statue for him and grogu's like or
Amanda's like can can I have that yeah
the statue is still the Droid which is
amazing we made the Statue out of the
Droid genius we didn't have to hire a
Statue Guy yeah yeah and so he needs a
Droid but in this scene a little
interesting moment from grief cargus
they ask why can't Cara Dune be your
Marshall oh yeah he's like well yeah
Twitter yeah and say no more yeah uh
bakara Dune we found out took moff
Gideon over to a New Republic your
tribunal yes a new Republic War tribunal
also I mean that's it kind of makes
sense that's filoni Dave filoni I think
gave an interview this week where he's
like they were like well how are you
going to address the car do you think
he's like there are billions of billions
of people in this galaxy yeah she can be
off doing something while someone else
is in front of the cameras I was
surprised they brought up her name at
all yeah I mean I think she was
important enough to of the future plans
of the show that they have to say
something yeah she was so involved in
those first two seasons so uh but we do
have some follow-ups on what's exactly
going to go down with this uh Judicial
System yeah the new Republic because
there's a lot of questions there yeah um
so yeah things go down with the Pirates
uh they try to reassemble ig-11 the
envelins the race of Abu Frick and they
steal the show as this race always does
their Delight yeah we get this great
Gandalf in the hospital well first they
assemble him but Mando tries to do it
himself and that does not go well how
could I probably could I forget this
well it's just the order Mando tries to
bring him back he does bring him back
and then ig11 rewards him by immediately
trying to kill him in groco and he's
like Terminator crawling around there's
no when uh when the just when the
Terminator is cut in half and it's just
crawling around with no legs still
because of the upper body fixated on
grogu how terrifying it is it when Den
does like a lateral pass yeah to grief
cargo grief card is like okay great he
just wants Amanda oh no he wants the
baby nope they use the bust yeah the
protocol droids the breast over right
which yeah the what a great move there
uh I think it was then ra7 protocol
Droid I'm not sure exactly what form
that was but for the win for the win
they are maybe the MVP of this episode I
think so because they've gotten and then
then we get the enzoids and they steal
the show from there boy oh boy my
favorite scene I mean you get Mando
sitting crisscross applesauce in that
little Hut well grief is like trying to
translate a very easily already
translatable language
this was an incredible moment of Comedy
I love this I uh and and yeah they find
out that he's not fixable he's too
broken so they got to find a new chip
yeah so uh for whatever reason maybe not
for whatever reason but didn't yarn
really really wants an IG style assassin
Jordan to accompany him to mandolin yeah
to me it seems like you know for him
obviously it's important for him to go
back to his roots to purify himself and
I think ig-11 represents his past as
well you know in in the past in season
one IG 11 saved Everybody by sacrificing
himself and taking out all those
Stormtroopers I think we're learning
more about dungeon's personality that he
is someone who relies on past
experiences to inform his future
decisions that's yes that's a that's a
good way of looking at it I think I just
love the idea that we could go to any uh
statue anywhere like to the Lincoln
Memorial actually can can I use that
giant Abraham Lincoln to help me I'm
going straight down to Burbank and
firing up that Batman statue out in
front of the AMC you know he can be used
he's like Excalibur the right person
comes along rubs his tummy yeah and then
he comes alive oh it's Tommy I've been
rubbing the wrong area anyway moving
along
he's got jacked calves so where are we
headed we're headed to see an old friend
or an old friend of me I guess because
she literally has to yeah oh wait no no
she's on the way to see both guys and
interrupted but he goes through this
asteroid belt that uh grief had talked
about earlier and then the Pirates are
back Bane is like you think you could
just shoot for my buds and walk away but
there's this little moment I think is
interesting where Dan is talking to
groguing and teases this little thing of
like you need to learn how to navigate
to be a true Mandalorian you have to
know how to walk so you'll never be lost
so you'll never be lost yeah uh so the
Pirates show up we get some great space
battle some nice sound effects home and
and they're kind of a rare in space
fight sequence in the ships you know we
get a lot of on the ground combat
Mandalorian they're cruising through an
asteroid belt I love that it was great I
mean this episode was really firing on
all cylinders it gave everything every
Star Wars this episode felt like it was
budgeted almost to like the uh like a
like a Star Wars movie yeah and you know
just like a half hour it felt like a
full film that we were watching but we
had we had Space Battles we had creepy
culty lore yes we had some politics
giant creatures giant giant monsters uh
and then uh sword lore right that's
that's that's everything you get
everyone else
Warped Tour too they were great they
opened up for ass party or whatever that
first one was
uh okay so we meet one of the uh one of
the Pirates yeah Gregorian Shard Shard
oh my God
what a glorious job he is with that the
leafy beard straight out of Pirates of
the Caribbean right yeah kind of or like
an INT you might say he had a beautiful
beard I love this guy uh the pirate's
King uh Commando uses his Subs uh his
boosters to he get the I love how easy
that he's like never trusts Pirates
oh I have a feeling though we will be
seeing Mr Shard soon I don't think he's
going to be gone for long no yeah for
sure absolutely he just looks too cool
they got to bring him back yeah then on
to Calavera which is the the home planet
or the home Moon of uh Mandalore home to
house Crees yeah and this is the first
time we actually see it it was
referenced in a couple episodes of Clone
Wars as being where the where the house
crease comes from but this is the first
time I think we actually see it at least
in live action yeah and it looks
impressive it's really cool the throne
room is very Game of Thrones you Vibe
the way it's so steep you gotta walk a
long distance it's very Dragonstone yeah
and we see the banners of house Crees
but it's empty it's empty because Boca
Town says well when I didn't come back
with the sword my my Army left they're
all running gigs around the Galaxy she
kind of also she she was in the Jonathan
Majors Kang sit the way he said in King
oh yeah yeah it's kind of like very
loosey-goosey leg draped over the side
there it is right there
so yeah that's what she's doing which I
if you sit in a chair for too long
eventually you're gonna get creative
with she's like I ain't helping you my
life is absolute dog ass I don't want to
hang out with you and all my friends are
gone you should just go do your own
thing if you think you can go down there
and breathe then do it yes she warns
that the the surface is toxic actually
she suggests he should go rule she's
like go take a dark saber and go rule
those people they don't like to wave it
around yeah like she knows how uh how
stupidly superficial the importance of
the sword is and I like that I like her
bitterness How stung she is I'm pissed
off she is it was hers it should have
belonged to her but you know what you
didn't win it in combat yeah you didn't
you didn't adopt a little Yoda and have
him help you take it
from Gustavo Frank that's right it's
late sorry guys let's get it going let's
get it going our big question the pergol
hyperspace what the frick are the purple
hyperspace well setting up the return of
Ezra Bridger I think they gotta be
anytime we reference or see the Pergo
whales it is in reference to that moment
in Star Wars Rebels where Ezra Bridger
and thrawn disappear now just a mention
of thrawn in season two of The
Mandalorian we're already thinking well
if thrawn is still alive Ezra is still
alive he's out there somewhere so he's
seeing these per I mean look pergles are
their own things but these are the these
space wheels that blast through
hyperspace the last time we saw his
refrigerator in season four of rebels uh
when he basically sacrificed himself to
save the rest of the ghost crew uh by
blasting himself and thrawn entangled up
in these pergol space hyperspace whales
and they blasted off to some unknown
region and then in the like the tag of
rebels we blasted off to the other side
of the the end of the Galactic Civil War
uh Ahsoka re unites with Sabine and
they're going off to find Ezra Bridger
so we have to assume that Ahsoka either
knows or is either knows where Ezra is
or is currently looking for him
somewhere out there maybe by looking for
thrawn she is looking for I think yeah
that was what I took away yeah like
finding thrawn means finding Ezra right
and so seeing these pergols right now
tell us yeah that that's that's where
things are yeah I think that's that's
where the overall the the television
Universe of these Star Wars shows is
leading up to thrawn in Ezra I think
right like it feels like it's a crash
course on that we got to deal with some
you know stole or lost Valor in the
Mandalorian the din jarens got to get be
able to put his helmet on and hug the
the uh the armorer again earn her
respect back yeah she is Mother after
all she as the kids would say you know
it's interesting that so much of this
episode is concerned with the what it
means to be an apostate and what it
means to be excommunicated from the
watch the children of the watch this is
Cole uh and that's what I love about it
we have these recurring motifs of
baptism of uh being enveloped by water
from the opening scene the opening
baptism of one of the new initiates one
of the Newfoundlands uh to the fact that
like uh grief is like why don't you sit
next to our hot springs like no that's
not the water I'm looking for and then
when he goes to Calavera he is wet he's
soaking wet because he's going through
the rain so he comes into that place
like he's being teased by water and then
so this idea of going through hyperspace
that looks like we're going through an
underwater tunnel the color blue and
looking over and seeing whales like it's
on the other side of an aquarium yeah
you know that's that's never not going
to be trippy right right and it just
looks the visuals are incredible it's
one of my favorite hyperspace scenes I
think and all of Star Wars but this is
the one thing that ties us into the rest
of the the Star Wars canonical lore
everything else is really really
grounded in the rights and rituals of
the Mandalorian Clan and that's what I
really love about this that's what I
think the most underappreciated thing
about about this series The Mandalorian
is you know when you're in Star Wars and
when you have Dave filoni
um in the director's chair for some of
these and and writing a lot of these
episodes there's it's always gonna
Branch out to other things from Rebels
from Clone Wars uh from the original
trilogy and in to Luke Skywalker but I
think what makes it really cool is just
the moments where we just get to know
these helmeted weirdos yes in in their
sword logic absolutely absolutely the
rituals and the strange rules and why
combat is so important it's all
fascinating and you're right it does
ground it especially when seconds later
a giant alligator snapping turtle can
invade yeah and then you're like all
right well I get why these people care
about each other so it does make me
still I'm still invested in it yeah now
earlier you said that the that grogu
might have summoned these per girls yeah
I don't know just in the way he was
looking at it looked like he was looking
intentionally out there like he or he
sensed them yeah he has this kind of
ability to connect with with fauna yeah
and we saw this with the rancor and the
Boba Fett finale this is something can
do and I think there might have been a
similar connection that he has with
these purposes In This Moment yeah and
that's kind of beautiful it's like
grogu's going to be the answer yeah that
Ahsoka needs to find Ezra unlike uh
George Lucas's doomed quote jar jar is
the key to all of this yeah I do believe
grogu may be the key to all of this
uh all right we have a lot more
questions that we want to address from
this episode of uh the Mandalorian
season three episode one uh but we want
to thank our sponsor who helped us make
this episode to make it even possible
quip yeah for sponsoring today's episode
of the break room presents Wikileaks
Amanda Lauren after show so I got the
water pick here Eric got the water pick
yeah okay so uh good hell starts with
good habits quip makes it Easy by
delivering all the Oral Care Essentials
you need to care for your mouth uh their
electric toothbrush has time Sonic
vibrations that keep going as long as
Dennis recommend you brush so you don't
even have to worry about if you're doing
enough yeah you don't have to sing the
song in your head you can just let that
thing Sonic Sonic its way through your
mouth so what Tommy has here is the
water pick yes you know what stop
littering the environment with your
plastic flosses
oh look at that in your in your picks
use a water pick be better for the
environment be better for the Galaxy you
never know who's out there that could be
Pergo hyperspace whales right all this
now if you go to getquip.com break room
right now you'll get your 20 off any
quip water flosser equipped toothbrush
or quips gum starter kit that's 20 off
any water floss or toothbrush or gum
starter kit at getquip.com that's
spelled
g-e-t-q-u-i-p.com slash breakroom quip
the good habits company oh baby so nice
I'll say it twice getquip.com break room
stop having a messy mouth anyway all
right what's our next question Eric uh
what the frick our Boca time and din
jarin gonna end this season in a duel
over the dark saber I feel like they
have to I feel like first of all we said
this off air but I'm going to say this
on air now so it's on record all Boca
time all we know from Boca town is just
what she's saying we don't have any if
it's true yeah she says everybody's left
her behind she's now there kind of
living in this nihilistic nothing
matters mood she might just be trying to
make herself seem weak to din so that
when the time is right she can duel him
for the dark saber and he'll be caught
unaware because he is always hyper aware
he's never lost he's always knows his
coordinates he's very good at knowing
exactly what's going on around him at
all the time so she might be trying to
much like you know uh but you know she
might be trying to mess up his
coordinates she might be trying to get
him off off base so I don't know I think
they're they're bound to fight and I
think that she might not be telling the
entire truth about what's going on with
her yeah we had uh some friends some
inside sources who were at the um the
premiere event in Hollywood and
reportedly Pedro Pascal said on stage
just wait till you see pointing to Katie
Sackhoff wait till you see what she does
to me and then fabric we're like yeah so
I think yeah she's gonna mess him up
there's gonna be an interesting conflict
I think she's going to betray him
somehow I don't know if she'll get the
darksaber but she's going to betray him
and it may cost her
everything let's talk about this moth
Gideon New Republic War tray oh yeah
dude death panels finally no I'm just
kidding I don't support death panels but
I did we have long speculated that we
were going to get into some like New
Republic politics through the MAF Gideon
arrest right like it was like oh we
might see how the judicial system in
this new Republic post Empire pre first
order era works and now we're finally
gonna get that and are we going to see
some familiar faces that are still alive
I don't know it's tough to tell I always
get confused who's still out there who's
still working well we we know that Leia
Organa is still playing an important
role in the new Republic she is leading
kind of the military faction she after
the end of the Galactic Civil War Leia
Organa had a reputation of obviously a
war hero a very highly respected uh
former Rebel figure uh but for a while
it was a secret that Darth Vader was in
a Skywalker her father uh that was later
released by her political foes and it
kind of doomed her political career so
she ended up taking her her Loyalists
and her supporters to kind of rally
inform what later became the the first
resist or the resistance you know the
military faction who who didn't trust
that everything was hunky-dory
um however she's still around I don't
know if she would be on the tribunal
it's just a little confusing when this
is because John Favreau just did an
interview earlier this week saying this
actually might take place like four
years after the pilot of the Mandalorian
right right you don't really know
exactly how much time has passed uh it
and that really would depend on like how
whether kylo Ren has been born yet at
this point we don't know how far into
the sequel era we are yeah but um yeah I
have to think maybe Admiral Akbar is on
that Admiral Akbar would be a good one
to recreate you know or or to bring back
you know it's unfortunate because
there's a man out there
with the Gift of Gab
with a political future but the casting
of it would be very confusing and that's
Lando Calrissian how do you bring Lando
back you can't bring Han Orlando back
because you have to they've both been
played by younger actors in movies that
took place prior to this event way prior
so you can't bring back uh Alden Aaron
right where's that and or or Donald
Glover to play those characters now
you'd have to do face map City and I
don't think anybody wants that but
wouldn't it be amazing if left okay we
see him was Prosecuting muff Gideon come
on come on it would be amazing let's
just animate that episode well
Christopher Lloyd is rumored to play a
character in the season I wonder if he
could be some uh some judge on this pan
I'm in I like it I mean Christopher
Lloyd can just do so much more goofball
yeah and uh potentially over the top
characters
let's not do that but Marty that's what
it is all right you got there all right
um okay these Pirates scoring Shard Bane
you said you think you're coming back
you gotta come back
they got to come back first of all I
don't know if I mean the the the the
four pirates that they that dropped in
Navarro right
those were all practical costumes were
they not I think so they looked
practical maybe they if they were done
if they were digitally animated they
they were animated to look practical
which was kind of incredible they did
look great I mean and just the way they
were playing it super scummy and yeah
awful and yeah I hope these guys come
back just I want all these Pirates to
come back I like these space pirates
even the dead ones I want the ghosts to
come back I like them and let's get a
Hondo ananka a cameo in here right I
shouldn't just be on Smuggler's run I
want to see him show that's right and
then fans have been dying yeah dying you
already have the live-action Hondo anaka
animatronics everyone Smuggler's run
just like get that same suit putting on
an actor he had been this [__] let's go
to pirates in here CAD Bane this [__]
indeed okay we're gonna leave it there
for this episode uh there's so much more
we could say but I got the Deep dive uh
we need to put you back in yourself so
you can finish our content for us yep
and I need to go find a group Pirates to
join we're gonna we get the breakdown
the Easter egg breakdown coming out on
the channel tomorrow just another
reminder uh unfortunately maybe next
week we might be able to get the
breakdown out on Wednesday that'd be
exciting
um but you know we didn't get these
until you know right up around when you
got it so we appreciate your patience
and again subscribe to our new channel
the Deep dive uh we had some fun stuff
coming your way you gotta do it baby you
gotta dive deep yeah and we will be
diving deep speaking to Christopher
Lloyd Tuesday March 7th will be our Deep
dive into Back to the Future it's such
it's gonna be such a great video You're
Gonna Love It
um and uh you can support our growing
Network by grabbing some Merchant nerd
riot.shop like that like the way
collection that we were wearing these
shirts feel and they look great you got
some aurabesh you get to translate and
then look like you know a true Star Wars
yeah to your friends uh this has been
some cool aurabesh hats too that's right
yeah go check everything on that
collection it's all great and uh we'd
love to if you ever see us out in the
public wearing it and you're wearing it
we'll give you a high five that's right
I might even give you a hug if you
consent
and if not a throat chop
thanks for watching Wikileaks everybody
keep watching this has been Tommy Victor
you can follow him at Tommy back so you
can follow me at eavas you can follow
new rockstars at new rockstars and uh
make sure to uh subscribe to this
channel that's right we'll see you next
week should we give everyone we have
spoken for Old Times sakes sure sure we
have spoken
[Music]
foreign